hi everyone I'm Ilana and today I wanted
to talk to you guys about the fake geek
problem the concepts that there are
people who are fake geeks or gamers and
pretend to like these things either for
attention or to seem different or to
impress someone even though they're
completely lying about it this really
annoys a lot of people understandably
when you see someone parading around
something you're really passionate about
just for their own personal and really
shallow gain it's really annoying
they're being fake they're kind of lying
and they're demeaning something that you
love which yeah it sucks
so being annoyed is absolutely justified
the problem I have is more with how the
geek organic community actually deals
with those people and that is by
generally just hurling abuse at them
it was Instagram specifically that
encouraged me to make this video where I
store accounts just posting a picture of
someone saying they don't really game
that's come there an attention hole and
basically just encouraging other people
to believe it I don't think that's much
of a solution even though I guess the
problem overall is quite masculine the
grand scheme of things being a bully
though is really just a wasted
opportunity if you really believe that
someone is faking interesting things or
even exaggerating it why would you just
take that time to encourage them to
actually get into it if you see someone
doing this or you think that they're
doing this just recommend them some
games I don't a much more selfish level
talking to someone about a game you've
both played or both finished is one of
the best things that I think can lead to
such amazing conversation there were two
people I met last week I still don't
know their names with complete strangers
and just talking about the loss of us
meant that we could talk for like half
an hour I have this awesome conversation
and it's such a cool experience more
gamers means more of those awesome
conversations more friends and probably
more games so instead of getting angry
and abusing a faker you could use that
circumstance to introduce them to
something that you love oh you could
just ignore them that was two and for
every angry abusive comment that you
don't type the more accepting the
community seems to someone who might not
be faking but isn't entirely interested
yet I for everyone you know type you
help to shift the image of gamers from
angry abusive jerks to something that is
more accepting and one that gamers might
be more proud to have not to mention the
loads of people who get accused of
faking or overly scrutinized even when
they actually not you could actually be
pushing someone really cool out of the
community based on a misjudgment even
though they
we're a part of it so yeah you can
totally get annoyed I get annoyed every
single time that I see someone say
gaming is their life and then it turns
out that they only play Call of Duty but
that's not my fault for getting annoyed
than it is theirs they aren't hurting me
no matter which way you look at it
they're not really hurting anyone
I gained literally nothing by getting
angry at those people even though I
might want to if you think someone is
faking their interest for attention I
vote you ignore them don't give them
that attention or do the complete
opposite don't give them the attention
they probably want or entice them into
the community
everyone win this video feels really
cheesy but I think the hate can get
really out of hand that a lot of people
feel like they're fighting a good cause
when they're getting angry at those
people but I've never seen anything good
come of it but let me know in the
comments below is anyone ever accused
you of faking and been totally wrong for
a really stupid reason because sometimes
it can be kind of funny while have you
called someone out in it and had an
actual positive outcome come from that
I'd be really interested to hear those
are just my thoughts thank you guys for
watching I'm Alana and I will see you
next time